hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast how digital holographic
microscopy can be used to explore cell
movements presented by kursi own
application specialist at face
holographic imaging I'm Alexis Krause of
laberd's
and I will be our moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's laberd's is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before I begin I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing here in the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Ahn I will now
turn the presentation over to her thank
you very much for the introduction I'm
really happy to be able to talk to you
about digital holographic microscopy and
cell movements so this show has two
learning objectives one is to understand
the technology and the potential of
digital or graphic microscopy in cell
imaging and the other is to understand
the possibilities and challenges of
measuring cell movements using digital
holographic microscopy so I hope that my
presentation we need you to have
obtained both learning objectives I
would just like to start saying that
there are several manufacturers of
digital holographic microscopes in the
world here are examples from five
manufactures I represent festival
breakfast imaging that manufactures the
holo monitor say them holography what is
that
in 1947 Dennis Gabor recorded how you
could improve image quality in electron
microscopy he was actually trying to
save some lenses make the setup easier
and smoother at that time there were
still not lasers available they were
readily available in the sixties though
depending on whom you're asking actually
the holographic story starts in the 60s
with the lasers but as a bore got the
Nobel Prize for this in 1971 I count his
record as the starting point digital
holography was possible to perform in
the end of the nineteen hundreds say
1995 1998 because at that time computers
started to be competent enough to handle
the heavy calculations demands demanded
by holographic imaging and the first
cell image is published we're just in
the beginning and the year 2000 to 2003
so then what is a hologram depending on
whom you're asking it's not actually a
picture it's a fifth breathitt recording
of a light-filled so what you see here
looking like an Australian desert or
something is actually a pattern on
effective paper that we if you put the
right kind of light on it
the teacher will emerge because the
light rays will bounce back forming a
picture and that picture can be viewed
without special spectacles or or other
intermediate projects you get a
three-dimensional image by putting the
correct kind of light onto this tray
the example here is the at that time
oldest man in the UK he was 110 when the
picture was captured thing with a
holographic image is that you can view
it from any angle as if the object is
really there because all parts in the
hologram it contains all information so
you twist them turn it and you can see
it from all angles as if you were
actually looking at this animal live so
how is then a hologram created it the
hologram is distracted pattern so it's
created by having a no light you can see
there our first arrow to the left you
have a light and the light is divided
into two beams one part one beam will go
to the objects and be changed by the
objects and then it will be bounced down
there
the Adderley like theme will go down be
mirrored towards the object beam but
that second beam will be unchanged it's
a reference beam it has the same
properties as the original light source
so when the object beam and the
reference beam meet there will be an
interference pattern best was captured
on the photographic plate
that's the sreyas pattern your hand
that's the interference pattern of the
two beams so that what property of the
light beams is then transferring into
the hologram usually you look at light
as a light wave coming up and down like
this in this example I have here the
blue object is such that the light beam
doesn't move up and down as much anymore
the intensity of the light is shifted by
that object
the green object can you see that the
light waves slowed down a bit when they
pass through that object the new slower
and then on the other side they go back
to originals that speed it's a phase
shifting object it slows down the night
most objects are like the yellow one on
the bottom it combined the combined
changing intensity of the lights and
changing the phase shift face of light
in the right image you can see when
France the red line is coming at us the
wave fronts coming like this so when the
light weight passes through the sample
like a cell for example they will slow
down depending on how thick the cell is
at a certain point so afterwards when
the light wave fronts roll out after
passing through the cell that would be
like an increment in the light wave the
light has been slowed down depending on
how thick or dense the cell is so based
on that slowing down it's called a phase
shift you can calculate the thickness of
the objects the cell in this case whole
thing is the cell you can calculate that
but it's the wavelength refractive index
of the cell and their activity index for
the cell medium so everything that we
show you is calculated by computer if
you put it into digital a lot of it so
what happens here in digital photography
is instead of having light hitting a
photographic plate the interference
pattern the combined light beams after
passing through the sample will hit a
sensor a digital sensor and the hologram
there will go into a computer that will
reconstruct cell images based on that
hologram remember originally
photographic plates you put light on it
you get the image here you have a
so capturing the hologram and then the
computer will calculate the images so
because everything is calculated
everything can be given as hard numbers
its quantitative as well as qualitative
you can see the thickness of the cells
for example but you can also calculate
how thick are they so what that's the
reconstructed image look like here are
here is an example first the left image
you can see it's flat from above and
then the right image is tilted and you
can see the 3 dimensional qualities of
the holographic images the colouring is
all pseudo colors it's just a way of
showing how thick the cells are you can
see the bars to the left but the very
thin the background is the light blue
the darker blue are thin parts of the
cells and the green and green white
yellowish are the really really thick
cells so the coloring gives you a scale
on thickness even in the two-dimensional
image so how can you work with these
images them I mean they look pretty but
you need to do something with them as
well so the first thing you always have
to do with a holographic image to a work
games is to identify what is cell and
what is background in this example you
see to the left a phase contrast image
the blue bar across the image is drawn
above certain like 5 cells in a row and
then you see the profile showing the
intensity of the image you can see it's
not easy from that profile to see rather
ourselves and grab various background
the to red limit is a holographic in the
middle image you see the same blue line
as in the face contrast image you can
see here also that profile on the cells
you can see that in this case the
profile
much clearer it's really obvious where
there is a cell and rather is background
so for a computer software it's much
easier to identify cells than using a
fixed contrast image so if you see the
holographic image to the right you can
see that the cells are circled that's
the book with a color that's the border
of the cell so everything that circle
will be counted as a cell and as soon as
you see the circle the computer can also
calculate based that on that cell so
[Music]
here you can see from this reconstructed
image the cells have been circled that's
the yellow and each thing with a blue
doctor in it is counted as a cell you
can see you already get the area you can
get the thickness you can get the the
volume of the cell you can get other
parameters as well just from circling
the cells so that's the that's the
benefit of holography that you can
actually get hard data out from
yourselves so from the single cell I
showed you before you can already get
data out here to take all the image
cells in one image frame and you get to
dig out from that cells you can also
have population data like this so here
you can compare all the cells example
here for fur thickness and volume so you
can here see what's but what's what is
the parameters of the cells so from a
single image frame capture at the one
time point you can get data like cell
morphology cell numbers circumference so
you can use these images for toxicity
studies for proliferation studies for
differentiation studies or quality
controls like in this exam
here they wanted to test if their gold
nanoparticles based on our on our
activity graphene surface would harm the
cells would it affect the cells so they
have mcf7 cells and l99 cells and they
just wanted to see what what happens so
that's an example of using single images
to get based on ourselves so I would not
like to show you a movie just to show
you what it looks like when you capture
several images from one single position
five minutes apart
it allows you to follow the cells over
time the same cells an individual cell
can be followed over time so here is the
video
you
as you could see you could follow the
cells through overtime through cell
divisions and when they moved around how
they interacted they shifted shape over
time this kind of time lapsing where you
can get actual heart date out from every
frame includes of course cell morphology
is a number conference but all say sorry
also cell movements and you can use them
for cell motility studies and cell
migration studies for kinetic studies
for cell cycle studies for mitosis
studies the toxicity kinetic studies for
kinetic proliferation studies and for
kinetic differentiation studies the
example here they have used a controller
and three different substances and they
have captured images you can see in the
in the diagrams the x-axis shows the
time so the images have been captured
over over a day and on the left you can
see parameters like cell number that's
the count you can see for control that
cell number increases prick'd opposite
the cell number is is stable over time
the stores for in the cell number is
pretty stable
as for Coulson it but when you look at
the confluence and compare that to the
cell numbers then you get interesting
things you can for example see that the
conference first increased in the top of
C treated cells but then the increase
what about so even though in at opposite
you have the same set number of cells
the conference increases and then it
flattens out the next column shows you
the cell area looking at the cell area
crypt opposite treated cells you can see
that the cell area follows the
conference this
indicates that the cells grow in size in
the area size even though their number
doesn't grow and that is because the top
of seed will inhibit them now we'll be
at blood cells in g2m phase of the cell
cycle meaning that the cells would be
rather large when they are blocked and
that means that cells will accumulate
cells will accumulate in the cell pouch
now looking at the second to last column
you have thickness and that does not
increase a lot it increases slightly but
the slight increase in thickness
together with the increase in area will
give you a very strong increase in
volume over time and if you look at the
cell image couple to act opposite that
of the autopsy treated cells you can
really see with your eyes that cells a
larger than the control ourselves this
is just an example of how you can get
different parameters you can fit them
together you can even have images
showing this you get hard numbers on
what happens to your cells over time in
culture
so once you have the time blacks you can
start picking out the data that I talked
about before so the list image you can
see that the cells have been framed with
a color and then in the right frame you
keys are right the image you can see
little tracks like the cells have tails
those tails show how the cells have
moved over time once you have done that
kind of analysis you have decided this
is a cell and this is how it moved over
time then you can get other data out so
this diagram shows you the optical
volume of a cell population over time so
we have population data but because you
have decided for each individual cell
what happens you also have the data for
individual cells so here is here is a
dividing cell and the diagram shows you
on the x-axis is the time of capture and
on the y-axis you have the volume of the
cell so you can see that rather early in
the plaintiffs capture that cell volume
was suddenly going down true that is a
typical cell division it happens quite
fast and very abrupt like this so in in
the a image you can see the cell when
it's starting to round up but when is
the the largest volume in the graph then
the B frame you can see that the cell
has divided but the cells have not yet
let's go each other that's just before
the abrupt decline in volume in the C
frame the cells have
I did and they have settled down
separately that's when the optical
volume is very very little and then
there is a slow increase in optical
volume over time and in the end the
optical volume will again be very very
high
and there will be a new cell division so
you can see builds the population what
happens to the cell population but you
can also see for each individual cell
what happens over time in the time
lapses so what can you use this for I
mean it's okay it's very nice that you
can see the cells on following but it's
actually also quite useful so the cell
tracking the little tails on the cells
can be used for motility in migration
studies I just would like to give a
short explanation on the terms motility
and migration because we're going to
talk about that later you can see the
little drawing it looks like my child
had done it the long movement like this
shows how a cell has moved over time
that's the motility then the red line
shows the shortest way from the starting
point to the end point that's the
migration so if you have a cell moving
at random the motility can go any way
whatever and the migration is usually a
very different from the motility very
much shorter but if you have a directed
cell movements the cell is moving with
some kind of aim the motility will be
closer to the migration there will be a
directness to the movements in the
diagram here you can see in this in the
all the cells from that population how
they have moved over time it looks like
like it's somebody Chiquita played with
yarn or something this is a ran
cell movement and how the cells every
position themselves over time and the
good thing is because this is digital
kelabra see you get hard data out of
this you can measure the motility you
measure the migration you measure them
until at the speed you get hard date out
from this so one example of people who
are actually used to motility to detect
something important here is people who
lived at cancer cells but used l99 cells
and genes one breast cancer cells and
see was there a difference in cell
movements if you have the cells in
normal SIA
or hypoxia usually in a tumor the
conditions are hypoxic there is not a
normal amount of oxygen inside the cells
these researchers wanted to know if that
would affect cell movements the they
used a hypoxic chamber and detected cell
movement but they could find no
difference in motility between cells in
hypoxia nor moxa in normal oxygen
compound what they still see though is
that what - their motility how far the
cells mood was directly connected to the
length of the cell cycle the longer the
cell cycle the third of the social
moving
that meant there aren't ways to see
cells that communicate with other cells
through extracellular vesicles this
extracellular vegetable vesicles contain
signaling substances they can be
purified in this case they purify these
extracellular vesicles from patients
with preeclampsia because they were
interested to see if they were in
special communication for monocytes in
the immune system of patients with
preeclampsia that could change the
morphology and the migratory action of
the Niemen systems because our pre
Ignacio
well they could see was if you look at
the left diagram but the control is the
one which says TG g GH pi sorry a
company must be n1 th P and there was
much less movements both for motility
and migration then if the cells were
linked with extracellular vesicles from
both preeclamptic patients and from
normal pregnancy patients so yes this
signaling system of extracellular
vesicles would affect the migration and
the mobility of cells of immune cells or
monocytes which I find it very
interesting here is another very
interesting way if you can just use the
migration and motility to study invasive
migration in dense cultures of breast
cancer cells so valentín is a marker for
mesenchymal to epithelial to mesenchymal
transition if you have limiting
upregulated the cells become less stiff
and here you can see that the blue is
the breast cancer cells with vimentin
when the red is breast cancer cells
without limiting therefore defect
experiments and in all of them you can
see that the red cells without limit in
would lose velocity the x axis here
shows confluence the cell set of their
cell sample so it's fragrance of
confluence templates and confluence and
in-between so the researchers here have
measured the cell motility depending on
confluence so you can see that with
limiting in the cells that's the blue
the more the higher at the confluence
the faster the cells will move but cells
without
they are not affected by the conference
and we also don't move as fast and this
is highly interesting because if you
have demons in you also have a more
invasive cancer a variety here is a
another example I also find fascinating
I'm sorry to treat you to all these
examples but I just love this there is
something that which I hope I can
pronounce which is called kind New Relic
acid which affects nerve signaling at
different levels and which also could be
neuroprotective in neurodegenerative
diseases and well it does it could
modulate the adhesion and locomotion of
brain and athili up cells so here they
have in that you can see the diagram to
the right they have down regulated and
regulated keine and you can see that no
crater later
sorry treated with china and you can see
that if you have i not described new
remi acid it will decrease migration it
will decrease motility it will decrease
the speed of the cells but you will also
see a slight change a slight effect on
morphology not much there and they have
measured that as well so here they
combined the motility measurements with
morphology data ok is there anything
else you can do using motility of the
cells yes you can do really involve
human studies
so wound healing is a classical method
you use that it sounds you have cells
which are really really dense and you
create a scratch or a space or a gap in
the cells depending upon your property
it's also called the scratch assay and
then you see how fast how fast that gap
is filling depending on
how to set up the experiments usually
people either capture an image in the
beginning and in the end or in the
beginning and maybe once in the middle
of them in the end to see how fast the
cells are moved in to fill the gap but
that way you don't know if the cells are
actually moved in or if the cells have
divided to fill that gap using
holography you can get a kinetic wound
healing essay so if you look at the left
image you can see there are dense cells
on the sides and there's a gap in the
middle and the right image the gap is
filled below you see how the cells have
moved when they fill the gap so in the
left diagram you can see how the cells
moved from the upper edge and down and
in the right diagram you see how cells
move from the lower edge and up through
the gap to fill the gap there is an
actual cell movement filling the gap you
can also see in the right wrap master
diagram a kinetic closure of the gap
images will be captured every 20 minutes
every half hour and you can follow how
the gap is closing overtime and you can
see exactly when it's closed we are now
going to look at a short movie just
showing a digital or graphic movie
showing how the gap is closing on on the
wound healing scratch gap and here is
the movie
you
as you could see the gap was filling
with moving cells there were almost new
cell divisions taking place so now you
have two benefits of wound healing
without holographic microscopy you can
follow the cell click they get closure
kinetically and you can ensure that it's
actually just cell movement and not cell
division that fills the gap people have
used this holographic microscopy to look
at to look at the wound healing so here
is an example where the user has to
consume the lower image to the left
first to show a bright field image a
white light image of the wound you can
see it's difficult to see the cells but
they're there and to the right you have
the holographic images you can see there
it's cells on the edges and you can see
that the the gap is slowly closing the
uppermost graph to the left shows the
cell pattern area of the gap so there's
a control and there are two treatments
and you can see there is a significant
difference over time that's the x-axis
how how the area the gap is covered by
the cells you can also use some digital
photography you can get the dry mass of
the cells you can also see how the
different treatments and the control
have a dry mass filled a gap over time
in this publication partly they have
also measured the thickness of the cell
layer as a parameter in the wound
healing gap in feeling they were dealing
that they have also looked at cell
volume and you can see that the
different treatments affected the cell
volume over time differently and based
on that cell volume they have
calculated the number of cells in the
gap so you can see here from different
angles how you can study wound healing
using digital mammography okay and the
next person using wound healing stretch
assays with digital holography has moved
that next Cillian which is important for
muscle control the mechanical stability
of the zet discs in the muscle fibers so
they looked at if if the neck ceiling
was also important for smooth muscles so
they have seen that the smooth muscle
cell movement was affected when their
ceiling was down regulated you can see
in the two diagrams to the right that
they have looked at wound healing with
two different ways to down-regulate neck
ceiling and this they have made a
scratch and then they see how the
conference in the scratch increases over
time so you can see that the two
different ways of downregulated
neck cilium will affect the wound
healing properties of the smooth muscle
cells in different ways these
researchers have looked at how melanoma
imbecility is affected by loss of the
cdkn2a and they have used wound healing
as one way of many to study cell
movement the migration properties so
they made a nice scratch you can see in
the image D here they could a border
where the cells are and then they
measured over time how this scratch was
decreasing so you can see if they have a
wild type C the C the Year cdkn2a there
is a difference in the stretch feeling
than if they have no so this could fail
that the loss of citycam to promote it
virility of this melanoma cells
[Music]
so what other applications can use it
for you can use digital or graphic
mascot microscopy and cell movement to
negate chemotaxis cell movement towards
or from some attractants or
repellant in this example that we have
here we just show that cells with no
fetal calf serum that is met treatment
they will move hardly at all
they will be very immature but as soon
as you induce chemotaxis using coughs
federal cough salem the cells will start
moving towards that you can see in the
tracks that there is a clear movement
downwards so to speak because downwards
is where the fetal calf serum is in this
publication researchers have used
digital holographic microscopy to study
chemotaxis for cells which have
different conditions their inner
matrigel they are not in a material the
collagen they have no collagen and they
have studied how cells were moving
towards the starving if they have
starved the cells of Hickock of serum so
the same starved cells they were moving
towards serum and they could see clear
differences with different treatments
and cell movements over time and that
was an era where different concentration
gradients and with different matrixes so
I'm now going to show you because you've
been suffering through a lot of talk of
just you can do this you can do that you
can do this I'm going to show you the
beauty of holographic imaging now with a
new movie the next movie and this movie
shows - it shows you l99 rose
fibroblasts which is giant and it will
you can see around it normal size ill 99
cells and they will all just divide like
popcorn and this large giant cell it
will not divide it
but so here is the vision
you
this is the kind of rare movement milk
movements that you can capture using
digital holography I would love to show
you one more piece of eye candy before I
complete my talk so this next movie will
just show you cells that are actually
exploding and which then will be well I
will call it helped by the friendly
neighbor but it ends up with a friendly
neighbor devouring the exploding cell
these are able topic explosions I will
have to add and then there is another
friendly neighbor who will play ball
with a small part of the a pop-tart
excel so these are d u 10.5 prostate
cancer cells which have been treated
with at opposite causing them off to
explode so here is the video
you
okay just to to now conclude my talk I
would just like to give you the last
benefits and limitations of digital
holographic microscopy so you can see
the benefits list is quite long because
I'm obviously in favor of digital ala
bracket microscopy where the limitations
list is quite short so for benefit here
you have very few sample preparations
you just see yourselves and it put them
onto the stage microscope stage and
that's it
you get quantitative hard data out from
your images and it is labeled free you
don't need any kind of labeling or
staining or anything like that that
makes it also very non-invasive the
cells are quite happily moving around in
there well I wouldn't say normal because
who says that the plastic vessel is
normal but as normal as possible the
cells just move around in their normal
environment you can also say that there
is no filter toxicity in the cells they
are not hurt by a really strong laser
light the laser is really really low
intensity it's a red laser of the most
but you can have any kind of laser but
usually it's very low intensity you can
therefore because of the label free
network toxicity yourself or anything
you can use really long term studies the
long longest study I found in a
publication so far is 10 days you can
also because of this non-invasive nest
cell friendliness you can follow cells
over time you get kinetic measurements
and built into the technology there is a
digital outer focus normally if you do
long term capturing ourselves like even
want to do time-lapse you would have to
adjust there was every
or you would need a really really
high-end macroscopic stage but in
holography in the software there is a
digital out-of-focus which will sort out
the focusing of the cells even over long
times so these are all strong pro-pro
benefits making you want to use digital
or graphic imaging the bad part is that
it's quite sensitive to scratches and
condensation things that will affect the
surface where the cells are growing okay
I think that's about it I hope you feel
really interested now on digital
photography so I will just say thank you
for listening to me and as you see to
the left here you need to think about
what your cells are up to tonight and
maybe things that you might need to
monitor them so they don't do anything
bad thank you thank you doctor arm for
that informative presentation we will
now start the Q&A portion of the webinar
and we'll address some of the most
commonly asked questions by our viewers
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on the
ask a question drop-down box located on
the far left to your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen and click the send
button our speaker will follow up with
your questions via email so let's get
started our first question is what types
of cells can be studied with digital
holography well digital holography per
se the technology per se can actually be
used to study almost any kind of cells
there are so many different setups
worldwide you can study bacteria you can
study you flagyl aids you can study
parasites you can study suspension cells
and around cells there is no limits
actually you just need to find the right
set up you know different kinds of cell
culture vessels be used again that is
depends on the setup the most important
thing is that the cell culture vessel
has good optical properties so the deme
know what you're after you can use EBD
slide 6 or plates 96-well plates special
glass things there are lots of
publications or people using strange
materials with nano wires on it as a
back as the source of growing of those
so it depends on what your need is and
you need to find the correct set up as I
said there are many setbacks worldwide
now doctor what is the resolution again
that depends on the set up everything
here comes down to set up holography per
se has a theoretical resolution of
Johnson now down to now nanometers the
set that we have mostly living at
tonight comes from the hollow monitor
from face on a bracket in a gene that
has a resolution of that half a
micrometer to micrometer depending on on
the background noise in your sample so
it's very different from setup to setup
how do you know what digital holography
is not excuse me how do you know that
digital holography is not photo toxic
usually I can't swim free from every
holographic kind of digital her breath
again set up on the world but usually
people use very low intensity lasers and
there is actually a person in Gothenburg
who has studied the impact of light on
cells crack a lot the midst of the laser
is useful needed to malarkey are so far
below the toxicity limits the filter
toxicity limit that they will not even
affect the printing expression in the
cells much less kill them off usually
actually the light intensity is so low
that you could either two children to
play with and it looks like we have time
for one more question for how long can
you monitor the cells you can actually
she was pretty freely the longest I know
of that anyone has studied the cell is
actually two four weeks
depends a bit on how often you want to
capture the images because in the end
you don't want to sit there with two
weeks of full-time living to investigate
but it's actually very free to choose I
would like to once again thank dr. Ahn
for her presentation I would also like
to thank laberd's for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December of
2018 you will receive an email from
laberd's letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that's all for now thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon goodbye